نعم جلال توقفت عمليه الاقتراع وكان الناس
حتى اخر دقيقه بل على العكس بعد انتهاء
فتره الاقتراع كان هناك من ادلب باصواتهم
وهذا قانوني طبعا على اعتبار انه يحق
لمسؤول اللجنه ان يبقي المجال للاقتراع
حتى ينتهي كل من دخلوا المركز الانتخابي
وهو ما حدث هنا لكن الان لم يعد هناك اي
من المنتخبين الان ستبدا عمليه الفرز جلال
الان الذي يجري حسب كل صندوق يتم التاكد
من كل
القوانين او ان الاجراءات وفقا للقوانين
التركيه عندما يتم التاكد تبدا عمليه
الفرز هؤلاء يبدو ان هذا في هذا المركز
الان انتهت عمليه التاكد من ان كل شيء على
ما يرام بعد قليل سيتم فتح هذا الصندوق
وتبدا عمليه الفرز الفرز هنا يكون
بمشاهده وجود ممثلي الاحزاب بالاضافه الى
موظفين الهيئه العليا للانتخابات وبالتالي
ستبدا عمليه الفرز في عموم تركيا وليس فقط
طبعا كما تعلم في هذا المركز بعد ذلك ربما
هذا المركز بداوا ارجو اطلب من الزميل
المصور التوجه الى هناك لان بدات عمليه
الفرد باعتبار انه انتهت التاكد من
الاجراءات القانونيه وبدات عمليه الفرز
هنا المعروف جلال انه في تاريخ الانتخابات
التركيه سرعه ايصال النتائج الان في كل
صندوق انتخابي يتم الفرز بسرعه كما تعلم
ممثلين كما ذكرت قبل قليل ممثلين عن
الاحزاب وايضا على المجلس الاعلى للانتخاب
بمجرد ان تتم عمليه الفرز يتم ارسال
النتائج مباشره الموثلين الاحزاب يصلوها
الى احزابهم ممثلوا الهيئه ايضا يرسلوها
الى الهيئه ويتم بشكل سريع ايضا الاعلان
عن النتائج الان طبعا تعلم من الخامسه
وحتى السادس يمنع منعا باتا التصريح باي
معلومات عن النتائج من السادسه وحتى
التاسعه يمكن يطلبون منا اخفاض الصوت من
من
السادسه وحتى التاسعه يسمح فقط بالاعلان
عن نتائج المجلس الاعلى للانتخاب لكن بعد
الساعه التاسعه يصبح الامر مفتوحا لكل
وسائل الاعلام ولكل من لديه معلومه بخصوص
نتائج الفرز يسمح للجميع الاعلان عنها
وبالتالي سرعه كبيره معروف فيها الاعلان
عن نتائج الفرز كثيرا ومن خلال تجاربنا
ومتابعتنا الانتخابات التركيه في حدود
الساعه تقريبا الحادي عشر يصبح كل شيء
واضح ويبقى فقط افرز اعداد قليله جدا من
الصناديق الاقتراع ربما يعني اكثر من 90%
يكون قد انتهى في حدود الساعه الحاديه عشر
هذا ما اعتدنا عليه وانا اعتقد انه هذه
الانتخابات ايضا لن تكون يعني مخت